the evidence of people smuggling is not
just in those who make it to Britain but
also the ones who don't
we found these three deflated boats
abandoned near a beach washed up on
shore after failed trips
now slashed by police officers so they
can't be used again
the boats are littered with discarded
belongings including babies nappies
we find a receipt for fuel
and the cover for an outboard motor
there are also instructions for wearing
a life vest well as the boats are about
to set off from the beach the people
Smugglers will tell their passengers to
leave behind their personal belongings
so that's what we've got here sleeping
bags rucksacks clothing shoes phone
chargers all of them abandoned by people
who are desperate to get down there and
go to Britain
within the boat a patent Mark Sky News
has verified it was registered in Turkey
and that's important a huge police
operation in Germany this year seized 60
boats from people Smugglers and said
they were being supplied from Turkey
from what we saw today that hasn't
changed
on the other side of the channel the
Lifeboat that led the rescue was being
cleaned down among those it saved were
12 unaccompanied minors
but the debts in the channel haven't
deterred people here
these migrants are worried that a friend
may be one of the victims but despite
that one of them has just paid two and a
half thousand pounds to a people
Smuggler to take him to Britain
do you meet him the person
I have contact numbers
in my friend phone so he call him and
talked to him
and and do you trust him
70 80 but
maybe he is trustable not sure but I
think
all right are you nervous about the
journey yes
it is freezing cold here and yet still
desperate people arrive every day
and lurking around are the Smugglers
always ready to take their money Adam
Parson Sky News Kelly